jp morgan has recently come out with a
brand new viewpoint on inflation hedge
assets they've specifically compared
bitcoin and gold now of course most
people who are younger they're buying
bitcoin most people have older they grew
up their entire lives being told that
gold was an inflation hedge
over the last 18 to 20 months we've seen
inflation explode we now have over five
percent cpi over four percent core
inflation
but during that same time period gold is
down seven or eight percent on a nominal
basis it's down double digits on a real
return basis bitcoin however is up over
400 percent
these two assets couldn't have a
different story at the same exact time
that governments were printing trillions
of dollars and inflation was ravaging on
now jp morgan specifically has called
out a couple of different things first
here are the key drivers as to why they
think more and more people are beginning
to look at bitcoin
they stated that the recent assurances
by u.s policymakers that there is no
intention to follow china's steps
towards banning the usage of mining of
cryptocurrencies really important the
second point was that there was a recent
rise of the lightning network and second
layer payment solutions helped by el
salvador's bitcoin adoption where more
than 3 million people about 50 percent
of the country's population now is using
bitcoin and then the third the
re-emergence of inflation concerns among
investors has renewed interest in the
usage of bitcoin as an inflation hedge
now of course if you were to ask a young
person would they rather own gold or
bitcoin of course they would rather own
bitcoin if you were to ask an
institution historically the answer
would have been gold
but now what we're seeing actually is
that the institutions are warming up to
the idea of bitcoin as the inflation
hedge humans are weird creatures we
simply look at what recently has
happened and begin to build a narrative
around it and that's what institutions
are doing they see that gold failed as
an inflation hedge a double-digit
negative real return asset not good in
the face of trillions of dollars printed
bitcoin however has the exact opposite
story and so institutions are beginning
to take notice on top of that we've also
seen some of the stalwarts the absolute
legends of wall street all begin to put
bitcoin into their personal portfolios
or the assets they manage that includes
everyone from stanley druckenmiller paul
tudor jones steve cohen george soros and
ray dalio regardless of what you think
about those individuals they provide the
air cover for the career risk
the second that those folks start to put
it into their portfolio
every other person on wall street every
other person in the financial markets
can say i put bitcoin in my portfolio
because the best investors in the world
put it in theirs you're covered the
career risk is gone we also have this
chart that shows the actual capital
flows between various types of funds
these are the cumulative flows in all
bitcoin funds and then gold etf holdings
what you can see is that there have been
outflows since the beginning of the year
in the gold etfs but there has been
drastic increase in capital flows to
bitcoin funds that's why the bitcoin
price is up because more people want to
buy than sell and that's why the gold
price is down because more people want
to sell than buy
markets and prices are determined by
supply and demand and as we know both of
these assets are relatively scarce
compared to other assets
gold has a narrative around scarcity
bitcoin has a verified scarcity those
things seem to be similar but they
couldn't be more different to a young
digitally native generation and so my
guess is that we will continue to see
drastic increase in demand for bitcoin
and gold will continue to be sold off by
the legacy holders we will see people
upgrading their portfolio upgrading
their inflation hedge assets from gold
to bitcoin gold's market cap will
continue to contract and bitcoins will
continue to expand i expect that at some
point there will be a crossing of
flipping of bitcoin and gold's market
cap but it will happen south of the 10
trillion dollar market cap that gold has
today gold will contract bitcoin will
expand last but not least we also have
if you look at the actual headlines of
many of these articles you can see that
there is jp morgan institutional
investors dump gold for bitcoin seeing
it as a better inflation hedge and jp
morgan's diamond calls bitcoin fool's
gold so even though the bank itself
jpmorgan chase has come out and said
that they believe adoption of bitcoin
will continue they believe that there
will be rising demand over time we can
also see that the head of the bank
himself believes that bitcoin will be
fool's gold bitcoin is not as valuable
as his peers or colleagues believe
we will see what happens the market will
be the referee but if history is any
indicator of the future it is likely
that the demand for bitcoin is going to
increase the demand for gold will
decrease and we will see more and more
quantitative easing and interest rate
manipulation which will force people
into inflation hedge assets if i had to
choose i would not be holding on to gold
gold is dead gold has failed as an
inflation hedge asset and the world is
waking up to it let's see what happens
but this is fascinating